foreign
[Music]
work
Maybe
I think I hear it so hopefully it works
for y'all too
foreign
do you all hear this one okay I think so
hopefully if not tell me
thank you
[Music]
Sanctuary was never meant for humankind
it was forged as a refuge from the war
between the High Heavens and the burning
instead
it became a new Battleground in this
eternal conflict
a secretive group called The haradrim
has kept mortal safe
but now this once powerful order is a
husk of what it was
and sanctuaries ancient creators have
returned to claim the hearts of
humankind
[Music]
this is the story of their downfall
not great
[Music]
foreign
town
[Music]
everywhere
fangs in the dark
to be
careful he's a wild one
what's it to you
also in hush
I'm sorry Wanderer you've come with a
difficult time
this madman just stumbled into town and
started causing trouble
damage spilling from the ruins kill us
all kill us all
ruins
what is he talking about
I'll explain
there is evil staring in the ruins to
the north
that poor monk back there must have gone
inside
even a holy man like him by whatever he
saw
could you protect us from whatever is
out there
we have nowhere else to turn
there is evil lurking in those ruins
I will drag it into the light of day
truly
oh thank you
so
much
[Music]
foreign
let's see
yes
[__]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
foreign
thank you
the old ruins are clear
your town should be safe now truly
by the Light you are Heaven Sent
oh I'm so sorry we haven't any coin to
offer
but we have hot stew good company and
stay for a pint
wash out the taste of the still
we'd be honored if you'd join us
you are safe
[Music]
uh
no
no no no no no no no no no
no no no
foreign
[Music]
hmm
my mother's blood
my mother's body
so
shall you witness her glory
before you die
huh
not ready yet
they're coming the whole damned Village
get up
get up we have to fight our way out
there
take them
light preserves
lost souls for all of you
[Music]
that was all of them night willing
Madman
those Heretics drugged me after I
returned from the ruins just like you
I came to my wits and escaped tried to
get inside the chapel but it was locked
and
what manner of evil is this
petos
of blood
okay
they must have fed them to me
they're Blasphemous ritual
how did they learn this
perhaps the answer lies in the chapel
they kept it locked up for a reason
the key might be on that woman who is
leading them
okay so in theory I hear myself now so
hopefully you do too
if not
hear me now
that was awkward because I was talking
that whole time
here we are
extremely quiet
I gotta fix it or bump the audio
hold on y'all
all right hopefully that's louder only
fire can cleanse the darkness in this
place
have a look inside but hurry tell me I
will prepare the torch and then if not
then I can boost it even more
can't hear it okay
all right hopefully that's better
blood petals I mean you guys don't
really hear me like the ones I was fed
sound gameplay sounds way louder okay
I'll turn
[Music]
shameful
our father has granted you a path to
Salvation
and yet you stray from it
every opportunity
a drink
and Gamble
you covet
and steal
shameful
sin
is there a path right
oh my dude
the Lords of hell are coming to devour
our world
salvation lies not in the light
but in you
faith
has taught you to deny your heart's
desire
and turned you into a prisoner
within yourself
break the chains
and discover
who you were meant to be
break the chains
and be beautiful
in sin
resist
ance
honey
it's me
I brought your child into this world
man
[Music]
they have awakened
the first
go to the dry steps and continue your
preparations
our true work
all right one second you came to thank
the light
okay hopefully that should be better and
I can turn it up more
oh
rip
and pepperonis
not like this blizzard
what does that mean still in the game
but then I got disconnected
no
where's my main character
I like to report a bug
no
back to sound and low really
turn it up quite a bit
so is low again okay
okay that's annoying
that's gonna be really loud I feel like
can I make a new character
nope all right do we
at the risk
do I back out
or do I
stay here
almost sounds like it's the wrong mic
me
I mean I don't think so
oh
wait I don't want to make I don't want
to make a new character
where's my character
I was playing I can't I can't even click
them oh wait
I I can't
I okay will Savage got disconnected okay
I don't know
I can oh
start game
Mike is very low
okay
we're gonna nope
okay got timed out
oh I don't know
I'm scared to like back out and then
have to come back to end
I relaunched and there's a cue um
I don't I don't want to be in a queue
though all right we're doing it all that
foreign
Maybe
I'm wondering just
go away do you have a quarter there you
go
we'll try again
it's a 30 minute Q
everyone saying they had to restart to
get a q all right
went to eight to six all right well well
that's good 48 minutes in queue
Let's Go 44. Get Hype
uh oh sorry let me get you this
oops
Spirit consumer if the play isn't ready
for you just um close your Battlenet
client and open it back up
yeah my volume is really low apparently
so I'll boost it again
um I don't know why it's doing that and
then it sounds really loud if I do this
but
here we go thanks bro appreciate it
um is that better
I wonder if they like
had to like spin down the servers to
start them back up for like maybe
console or other players
sounds like you're too far from them
like I know that's what's blowing my
mind I'm literally right next to it
um I can try to fix it I guess while
we're in queue
y'all might lose some of the game audio
for a second while I try to fix this
foreign
I don't know if that's better though
it's probably the same
thank you
[Music]
it's sped up a little bit there it went
from like 41 to 37 so I'll probably just
stay I would suggest not leaving Q if
you're in one it'll probably just be
worse
[Music]
sorry y'all
um
just figured there wasn't much to talk
about during the queue I guess but
realizing that it's probably boring for
you if I don't talk to you so
hopefully it's okay
um hopefully I'm not too loud I realize
I sound kind of far away uh but you know
hopefully it's better than not being
able to hear me at all
so hope you're having a good day
um sorry that you know people are
getting punted out and having to kind of
come back in it's happening to other
people my friend got booted off too so
um some people are probably getting in
faster than others but uh you know it's
a beta
hopefully you know
having this happen will be better for
them on launch don't know we'll have to
see
um and then next weekend presumably will
be even more people because it'll be
open Beta so anybody that wants to play
can play so
might be might be even
um more nutty next week
realize there's probably a lot of
ambient noise that the game is not
covering so I guess I should just keep
talking
um I guess what classes are people
um in
the uh chat looking forward to playing
check something too real quick one sec
[Music]
um hopefully I'll hear me still tell me
if you don't
um I'm trying to I tried changing like
one little thing but you guys tell me uh
if
it works or not
lagmancer Druid Rogue sort because necro
is locky and echo's next week
seeing the church was cool
um
we hear you thank you bojamin or boja M
sorry bojam M sorry
thank you Roberto thanks for that
yeah
I've been having some audio issues this
morning so I have to ask because they
couldn't hear me earlier
are next week
um
candidly like
playing Diablo 2 Diablo 3 I'd rather
have seen Paladin make it because I
played a lot of Pally someone mentioned
assassin earlier I like Assassin a lot
too
um we'll see who we get right with the
with the coming
potential expansion I would imagine
right like there's got to be more
characters on the way or at least a
character I don't know kind of like
Reaper of Souls brought the Crusader
um
uh 100 with you bojan and uh the game
feels fun and nostalgic but yeah I need
to wait for the full release to enjoy it
like it's meant to be played yeah this
is only a slice I think it's only like
what act one or the first chapter Etc so
we're not gonna see too much you get to
25 that [__] uh when I played it for
preview that did unlock like the
ultimate skill it felt okay like
um obviously not optimal because it
didn't have like full gear and all that
stuff so
it's hard to really say like I'm I'm
with you I'm always about the end game
and kind of like full builds and things
like that uh you know you want to
synergize the legendaries and things
like that
and
that's when Diablo is kind of the most
fun
um really sorry everyone that we're kind
of stuck in queue we got to play for
about 10-15 minutes and then we got
booted now we're in queue
um sounds like it's happening to other
people other streamers as well
um
so you know
is what it is Michelle's gonna go make
dinner since they're supporting me a
cute that's not a bad idea you know make
your dinner come back
um you know make your dinner eat your
dinner and then come back and then
you're just good to go you're fueled up
to play for a while
yeah everyone's kind of having the same
issue of being able to play for a little
bit getting kicked out and then now um
being stuck in a queue so
um
you know bear with us everyone we'll try
to get back in and play for like an hour
maybe hour and a half give or take
um see how far we can get I was really
hoping to kind of uh well one not get
kicked out but two maybe get far enough
that we could try to check out the
stronghold there's definitely a
stronghold in Act One
um but I want to say it might be like in
the teens that it's it's a pretty pretty
hard solo
um definitely need to be a little bit
leveled up and stuff like that
I'm Matthew Foster and this looks about
right I mean hey this is just like the
the old days right
um I remember launch day of D3 I just
kept getting air at 33 or I can't
remember the exact error but you know
the one I'm talking about if you play D3
and we just kind of sat there right
trying to get in
um and again hopefully you know this
gives this and next week's open Beta
hopefully this just helps them with
um you know launch really hopefully
but I mean realistically too
this happens with Wow right all the time
like even with big expansions there's
always a cue I feel like it really ramps
up right those first like couple days
when everyone's excitement's super high
and then it it gets progressively better
each day after that
error 37 sorry that I was close error 37
that was the that was the one thank you
bojem
um
so yeah I don't know you made it to
level five finish the dungeon before
you're getting kicked nice
that's roughly where I was at zero
um
nice low cut I'm happy that you're
playing happy for anyone that are still
playing you know where are all the
streamers doing Q streaming today uh you
know it could be a chair stream too but
here we are right
yeah risu it it's not it's not a great
feeling
um and all like you know like me telling
you that it's beta and that it's a work
in progress is probably not the answer
you want because it's a big company
obviously you paid
um maybe you know maybe to someone's
point in chat maybe they can extend the
um beta like maybe half day or something
like that or however long they have
issues for uh maybe to kind of you know
make up for the fact that people are
losing time right now
um
I think there's just a lot of folks
trying to play again which makes me kind
of worried about next week just because
open Beta just means a huge swath that
people are going to be playing
um it's tough right like because you
want to play first day but I'm I'm
guessing you know if you you
came if you you actually started playing
like later you know hours later then you
probably probably be having less issues
but I think since it's like right at
like
the launch of the beta at like 9 A.M
everyone's trying to play right now
so
sorry that it's sorry that we're in Q
hell
um
but yeah a lot of people getting to
level four level five and getting kicked
level six there for D notorious so yeah
like it seems pretty
even my friend you know he he sent me a
message he's like rip got kicked oh and
then he came to this stream and he's
like oh you got kicked too and I was
like yep I totally did
I totally did
but hey we're all we're all in this
together oh geez at 91 minutes uh
leave that up maybe go watch a movie and
come back or watch an episode of Last of
Us or something come back I don't know
or you can stay here and chat with me
that's cool too
um
I don't think your character is deleted
Hector because like I have to imagine my
character is still there we'll find out
when we get back
um
but oh Matthew fosterling with a seven
minute I'm jealous you got you're 15
minutes ahead of me
thanks Alex I appreciate it you sound
like a you sound like a super cool
commenter chatter appreciate you being
here appreciate everyone being here
really on a Friday
uh during Early Access beta
we can all uh
coalesce on the fact that we're all in
queue together it wouldn't really be a
Diablo Tech launch right without a cue
of some sort or a blizzard Tech launch I
guess
no Necker or Druid this week that's
right uh they're they unlock next week
during open beta and then the world boss
is
um I think tomorrow and Sunday and then
I'm not sure about next weekend
uh Jose says already using PS5 yeah I
think some of the folks that I know on
Console are okay
um I think PC is where a lot of the
disconnects I'm I'm hearing about are
happening at
what's up Inglorious welcome welcome
this is gameplay footage yeah you know
it's it's
there's something kind of funny about it
though like as you know when we were
playing everyone's commenting on you
know the gameplay not looking the way
they want it to or not being as nice as
they expected and then now we're in
queue and we're just getting trolled
about
showing gameplay oh
hope it Smooths out by 4 30 EST I think
so I think so Robert I think it'll be
pretty pretty good by then I imagine
also less people will probably be trying
to queue they might give up you know
they might come back tomorrow or
something
I'm at 34 just 10 minutes behind says
just some dude
nice nice okay so it's it's not it's not
fake oh geez 152 minutes man if I if if
we find when we finally get in if I get
kicked again and it's like a 30 40
minute type cue I'm gonna have to end
the Stream
um that's there's no way I can't sit
around for another 40 minutes but when
we get in I'm definitely gonna get as
far as we can and yeah zero says they're
on PS5 they're kicked after 43 minutes
now the queue is 58 minutes but down to
34. so everyone's kind of experiencing
it kind of across the board
um some a lot worse than others Marco
saying 116 minutes that's kind of
that's kind of a lot
oh Dr Travis C with 19 let's go uh
Gastly with 16. hey this is this chat's
now about what people serve at Q times
start uh either how low or high it is
don't end the stream all right I won't
uh I'll I I won't
should see how see who has the highest
queue time I think it was 116 the
highest so far in chat I mean I know
what's gonna happen now people are gonna
make times up but like I think 116 might
have been one of the highest that's
basically almost two hours
longest cue to get a KFC sandwich yeah
yeah
151 my bad Shadow gamer with a 151
um I would say shadow gamer if you want
leave it on
and then maybe go do something else for
now
because geez
I don't think anyone's gonna top that
one 150 plus minute one because that's
that's kind of nuts
yeah I don't know Robert I I feel like
it's probably pretty big because now now
like this launch of D4 is across
multiple platforms compared to D3 which
was just PC only to start right so
can you Co-op now uh Ethel Bert so if
you're on PC you need to have another
you know friend or anyone from chat even
if you want to just like friend you up
on Battlenet and then on PC that's how
you would Co-op together I think there's
I believe not not I think there is couch
Co-op for console meaning that you only
need one key to play but you do need the
your Co-op partner couch Co-op partner
to log into their Battlenet account to
like sync it that way there's um
information on how to do that online but
uh couch Co-op if you want to do it only
need one key but two Battlenet accounts
to be like logged in or you know synced
together on PC you'll need two two keys
basically and there's a couple ways to
get those right now you can either buy
like a KFC sandwich uh the Double Downs
one of them which is like the two Fried
Chicken
and whatnot sandwich and then the um
the other way is to pre-order so
wow it's going up for you housing view I
haven't heard anyone else come in here
to say that like their time on the Queue
went up that's kind of scary
the lighting in the game dramatically
changes during Co-op apparently really
like like does it like
does it go does it like a lot brighter
tie
we're almost there 16 minutes let's go
come on
you can connect two PCS to a TV and play
couch Cove that well not really zupa how
are you gonna get the visual of the
other machine
uh I guess if you split screen the TV I
guess
um
[Music]
122 minutes for Bart yikes
what class are you gonna play uh I have
a sorcerer that I made that I'm gonna
play first
um I don't know weirdly
for me going back to like D2 and D3 days
I really wish I went sorcerer risks or
whiz first or wizard first because it's
probably the better farming class
to just like you know get stuff done now
that's not to say that you can't do that
on any character and who knows what the
um
you know how drops and stuff work but I
don't know historically like a range
class first is almost like you know
better to like
uh use first as your first character and
then you go back and like make your
second character but that's if you want
to make multiple characters if you're
not trying to min max necessarily then
you know don't worry about that pick the
class you want to play
down to 24 still 10 minutes behind me
huh okay that's cool just some dude
thank you for the update uh yeah we got
to see the brutal cutscene with Lilith
uh before we got kicked that's literally
right before we got kicked we finished
that cutscene
um I forget the uh priest's name the the
person we're saying is basically like a
Deckard cane wannabe uh he said
something and then we got booted thank
you
yeah zero I mean people who participate
in a beta and are upset even though it's
not functioning perfectly then you know
it's just the nature of you know the
internet really
um
maybe this is a rant but I feel like you
know
this generation
I don't want to say it's entitled maybe
a little bit but you know they need that
instant kind of gratification they need
things to be working
um but I also see the other side you
know if you are paying to pre-order
something you do love the game and you
do want to play the game but you know
you probably have expectations right
like if they say the beta is going to
start at 9am you're probably thinking
cool I'm gonna be able to hop on at some
time around 9 A.M maybe there's a queue
and play without there being too many
issues but then you know we're reading
chat here and you have people with 60
minutes left 119 minutes left 154
minutes left and that's kind of that's
kind of painful right like if you have
to wait two hours to play something
that's kind of painful right
um
so you know
uh Western gamer says this generation is
entitled I mean yeah I I'm saying this
as a father like and my son's only like
almost three but he um
he he definitely needs instant
gratification oh thanks John Luke I will
go off he definitely needs instant
gratification and maybe that's you know
me and my wife's fault for not trying to
teach him patience but like as I try to
teach him patients I just realized like
Yep this is just kind of like
the rest of the the internet in the
world you know like
if we don't get what we want right away
we just pitchforks up right pitchforks
and torches and want to burn it all down
right nine minutes hey we hit single
digits come on let's go
should have just released a single
player I mean yeah those are the good
old days open your minds I that doesn't
exist too much anymore
I mean Morton that's always been a a
tough one for me right even with even
for like non-bedas uh they brought
Morton brought up the point that you
know it's not a beta problem it's not a
certain problem they know how many
people bought to get access and they
should try to accommodate for that but
it's just like World of Warcraft right
it always like I said earlier the first
couple days gets slammed right and
they're like and like we wonder why they
don't just spin up more servers
obviously there's cost involved right
but
then it kind of Mellows out and it
tapers off and then it's fine right so
they don't I agree with you like they
don't do their necessarily their best
to like ramp up for those first couple
days but they also know that like
it's probably gonna be fine it's just
annoying you know and I don't know I
don't know enough about the back end and
like the cost implications to know
exactly why but I've seen it with every
WoW expansion even though I don't play
it I'm like you know that there's going
to be a huge influx of new players
returning players
um Etc on your first day of expansion
yet you're not ramping up to to
accommodate the fact that you know that
that's going to happen instead they just
try to adjust with like a load and
server cues and things like that right
so
some people are getting close
um solohan with 11 he's almost gonna hit
single digits
um
remember Lost Art cues for days I didn't
actually play it um it looked fun though
it's funny because like I think when
Lost Ark was about to come out that's
when we found out there was gonna or
like roughly around the same time we
found out there was gonna be like horses
in Diablo 4 and I'm like oh hey
look at that
I'm really hoping that uh just so you
all know when I played uh a preview
build at the end of last year there was
the horse wasn't in the game yet or like
sorry you couldn't access the horse I'm
hoping you can access the horse here in
the preview but maybe they view it as
like you're only in the first area so
you don't need it
um but I don't know
yeah Jay Beetle they want to
um test and run things slim to see how
much they can push it that's very true
uh again I'm sure there's cost savings
implications to that
started at 120 Minutes down to 93
minutes then it hit escape on the wrong
monitor no no Adam I'm so sorry
yeah Jack I mean
I think people
think and maybe know that there's going
to be a cue but they still don't want it
it still doesn't make them feel good
that like they're like well I want to
just be able to play the game like let
me play the game right
and they're entitled to their opinion
even if it's right or wrong
but
you know I would say more than half
if not maybe even 66 to 75 percent of
people are probably like yo I I'm
supposed to be able to play right now
what the hell like let me play
and maybe because I've just experienced
this so so much with blizzard
it's kind of like I am just so used to
it now I mean for all the people that
have a hundred plus a minute Q like I
would just be like nope I'm just gonna
leave this and go do something else I'll
Tab and like I don't know do something
right uh
but I fortunately ours is about 40
minutes I get to chat with you guys
which is awesome
um my friend's still debating if they
should get the game I mean tell them to
play next week uh okay I can't say your
name kixels
um because open Beta is next week and if
not and you have it on Console then they
could you know play co-op with you
potentially
um in person
beaujan I hope I don't crash again bye
bye bye I hope I don't crash again too
um
all streamers I checked out aren't cute
yeah I mean that's I I think everyone's
in the same boat I mean at least from
that standpoint you know for all the
people that go oh streamers have like
private access and like they have they
have an in like
hey we're all kind of in the same boat
here you know to different degrees
dead code don't say that don't say it's
114 to play another 10. I can't I will I
will I won't be so sad if um if I get
through this queue and then I I uh I
can't you know play for more than 10
minutes open your mind congrats enjoy
please don't get kicked either please be
able to play for like one plus hour that
would be awesome
uh yeah Western gamer I mean but that
but that's what the internet is right
the people are gonna be upset and
they're gonna they're gonna like send
their their
negative emotions
to to the person that's causing them
said negative emotions right so
I mean hell like I said if you either
bought a sandwich or you pre-ordered the
game you spent some level of money to
play so to speak and
you know
so you're entitled to be you know upset
a little bit but also within the
expectations I would hope that people
understand that this stuff happens all
the time especially with a stress test
slash but it's they haven't marked it as
a stress test right they've marked it as
a beta test which means it's not final
which means you know
it's it's in a testing phase although we
can all agree in chat we know that come
launch day there will be cues lit like
there will be cues on launch day there
is there is
I I can only I'll bet you five dollars
right now actually I shouldn't do that
because there's too many people in chat
I will bet everyone a penny I'm cute
um I will bet everyone a penny there
will be cues day one and I don't think
any I think anyone that's smart and has
played these games for a long time
probably wouldn't bet me right because
well I guess for a penny you would but
um
come on get me in I'm cued with no timer
what does this even mean
there's an authenticating pending one
and you've been in that one for 30
minutes
Say It Ain't So Camille
though
oh I'm logging in oh all right Camille
oh okay I I shouldn't jinx anything yet
I'm not actually in the game yet
no this is literally the street okay
no just go away just go away we just
want to play our game we just want to
play our game my character is still
there
I didn't realize I had the red eye
makeup we'll get a helmet we'll cover
that up
oh this is what he meant did he mean
cute for game start game pending
I don't know either way oh oh all right
I'm just shutting I'm shutting up I'm
shutting up let's just play Let's just
let's just get through it do you guys
want me to stop talking I'll just play
we'll just go ham
come on please
okay okay okay okay okay
dude it oh no it like kicked me back
from where I was
it like rolled back
keep talking okay
talk twice as much I can't that's
impossible
um I'm gonna skip the Cinematic
I will prepare the torch we saw the
Cinematic I'm sorry I'm skipping it
I'm skipping it
I'm skipping it this is where we were
before I got kicked
you collapsed inside
I thought that Darkness had swallowed
you I dragged you here and put this
cursed place to the torch what happened
to you in there
I saw
okay you got it
sorry if I said that wrong
no play the cinema I'm sorry I I I don't
want to take the chance
I don't even want I don't even want
conversations you all want to see the
gameplay I want to see the gameplay
oh do I have to equip that
oh no okay sorry I hit the social tab oh
it's it's kind of lagging
oh that's an altar Lilith
um
oh let's go in a dungeon uh small
dungeon
do I have shoes
yeah they won't have lots of detail um
later I think they said
really nope no purple
I got scammed this ice-worn seller I
came down here for loot
all right I gotta find the herpes Cavern
yeah we don't even care about 10 gold
right now we don't got time
oh great shrine
oh we rich
oh shhh
are we going the wrong way
yeah it was worth it for the shrine
let me look at the map uh all right
oh so much gold
I love how frantic he's I don't want to
get kicked man
we waited 40 minutes to get back in the
game
oh it's a little it's a little laggy for
me so if you see any of that
that stuttering or whatever it's it's it
is happening to me right now but
that's probably a little bit expected
given everything that we know is going
on here
so just bear with it
roll up the punches game sound up please
okay hold on
all right I turned it up
Mass clicks are immersive I'm sorry
I know
can't give you both I can either stop
talking and you stop hearing the clicks
which is totally fine with me too
uh you would hear my loud mechanical
keyboard if it was a wasd
click and hold does work sorry it's like
a bad habit kind of thing I will I would
do that though
except for this stuff that I have no
choice sorry
oh you're good thank you yeah I just
know it's annoying I I mean I I hear I
know it's diablo but the clicks man
all right uh you guys want to see all
the story right
oh thanks I I wish I could give you a
hug as you wait
controller is the only way
I could move to a controller if you want
me to
there's a hermit
foreign
PS5 version should be online but people
are confused I think
if you're going to trespass into my home
rightful through my things
then at least have the decency to join
me for supper
um ysd is not usable right now
uh visuals do look better than they do
on stream that's just how it's going to
be sorry I'll
that's quite the story
I wish it wasn't true
but it is
sorry Brew I'll try to do click and hold
just a habit friendly villages
they gave you the blood of Lewis
blood of a demon
not just any demon
the daughter of hatred the mother of
sanctuary
she was banished ages ago
but this world is her creation
it was prophesied she would come back
what does she want
that's the question
Sanctuary has always been trapped amid
the Eternal conflict
a war between Angels and Demons
but Lilith serves neither side
she has her own plans for us
and me
am I corrupted
not sure yet
share a connection
what will you do about it
I'll turn down my audio tell me if that
works find out what she's off to
good
then we're in this together
rest while you can
then we'll start to be overshot
I actually just got back in after
getting kicked for like 40 minutes
tell me if if y'all are good with uh
game audio and voice audio I'm happy to
just stop talking and play too
uh good luck David Kong I hope you don't
get kicked
voice is real loud
audio is good uh
uh conflicting
game sounds good all right thank you all
I'll just stay with it for now it sounds
like the majority is saying good and a
few that are saying um
wait uh I gotta speak to Laura
I'm going the right way just
didn't talk to my mans here
the angel in Arias
I'm sure you've heard the Cathedral of
light yeah zero I think it rolled back a
little bit
well he's real
an angel walks Among Us
and when he learns that Lilith is here
blood will flow
they are ancient enemies
they'll drag the whole damn world into
their Feud unless we can stop it
let's not linga
okay voice is a little loud that's fine
I'm gonna not talk as much anyways
hold to enter the city you must we have
no time for this
to answer key of Assad you must perform
a cleansing ritual meaningless gesture
but some people say comfort in it
just let him through that I've tried for
years to get Laura to do the ritual
no I didn't have to totally start all
over but it definitely re-rolled me a
little bit
take a piece of holy Cedarwood from the
shrine and inscribe it with a sin which
troubles you
great
you must feel as though a great weight
has been lifted from you
welcome to kyovashad
Dean thanks for the tip on gunfire I'm
sure it doesn't really matter as much in
the beginning oh
so what did you write on that piece of
wood
something about greed or gluttony I'm
off to the dry steps in search of that
Pale Man from your vision
tattoos sway back
cloudy eyes
let's put things practically
[Music]
nah so the old man's finally decided to
buy it back
knowing him he didn't if he wants his
weapon
wait
the old man sold me this too he said he
didn't need it anymore but
I think he'd want it back all the same
no charge
[Music]
arms for the light
foreign
that's just happening for me right now
in game
he also gave me this amulet
what is it
yeah I mean I finally got back in after
40 minute wait until the scholars and
ages
there is another haradron
his breadth of knowledge about demons is
equal only to his hubris
sounds like
but don't forget
I'm gonna skip some of this dialogue
just to play through you want me to
lower my mic I can do that because
finding her and stopping whatever she
has plan
sometimes our paths in life are set to
collide
we just don't know it
whether it is by accident or Fate's hand
there is deeply the progress was saved
from week one Early Access to open Beta
but not to the final game that the blood
of Lilith
saved by a lone Monk
different lives and incidents Drawn
Together
I did not know Humanity from the
daughter of hatred
[Music]
the game is lagging a little bit oh my
gosh I know it's coming out
um so if I stutter at all it's it's it's
happening to me in the game a little bit
right now but like I said it's probably
expected given everyone's trying to get
in the game and they're they're probably
doing the best that they can so just
bear with it for now I apologize
yes
I'm gonna skip through a decent amount
of dialogue I hope that doesn't bother
anyone but I want us to be able to see
gameplay and all that stuff so that
that's why I'm gonna do some of that
here and there okay
sorcerer is feeling good yes
the new militia recruits have been
training night and day they deserve a
little praise mind giving them a cheer
for me I will handle it
hello
impressive
thanks
I hope they don't get used to it
we were born in sin
children
the darkness
father's light can be sought through
penitence and face
walk in the light
we must be ever Vigilant against sin
brother yes Reverend mother let the
light of anarius burn away wickedness
let not Temptation lead you from his
holy Radiance let righteousness sear
away a corruption and sin cast out thy
Darkness for only light must remain cast
out thine Darkness for only light must
remain
is this the one from Neves
yes reverent mother
did loras not accompany you Boron
um I got to play the preview which is
the same as what everyone's gonna get to
experience it this weekend I didn't get
to fight the world boss
um and I didn't get to play nekroger
from what I played I enjoyed it but I'm
also like a Min maxer who wants to play
end game so I'm holding back my
reservations on like really true
opinions because it's hard to know how
I'm gonna feel until I get to that part
of the game
the description matches too closely to
reciting invest
if you would travel to your lesson and
take stock of events there
you would have the Gratitude of the
Cathedral of light
I had thought to send Laura but again he
fails in his duty
with or without Lawrence
the will of an artist shall be done
[Music]
here take the knights report before you
go
Reverend mother I received a report of a
potential demon sighting horned woman
near yelesner Minds
performed routine inspection nothing yet
sent in Priest and escort of knights
will report in when we find something
[Music]
foreign
again it's beta apologies
um if you see me like stuttering at all
like I am right now oh
yeah you will in a second
it's it's in the game a little bit right
now so again just be patient sorry
um
good
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Jefferson if that's true about the man
the person with a 2000 minute Q that's
that's kind of that's kind of a lot
reply of I require a host of intact cool
Hearts from this adventure out and
retrieve this myself but I'm more
accustomed to dealing with the fully
dead
your discretion this should be a veteran
Aiden
what do you need prava sent me
I'm looking for Vigo
you and that nuisance of a child both
girls been nagging us about a demon
woman all week
vigo's gone looking into her claims he
should be at the mining camp north of
here all escort of knights went missing
her last week
foreign
thank you
whoa I'm rubber banding a little bit now
okay
More Strangers in the camp
all right Ada DK they're definitely
gonna need more for next week at UV go I
would say
I know what I saw
she had horns like a beast strod right
past where you stand
think my mother's trapped in there with
her
you let my mother through sir shouldn't
you be responsible for her safety
we have soldiers stationed inside who
should be worried about them too
maybe you can help me
foreign
the horned woman
is the demon Lilith
no
can't be
it's me that name
you speak of the daughter of hatred
mentioned me
she wasn't angry was she
it's more than your job at stake here
come on
let's get this over with
what
the damn hoist is stuck
you've got to go on foot
look out
hey that's my mother's charm on your
wrist
hmm it's mine now girl uh Jaren I didn't
lower any graphics or anything I let her
and her friend
[Music]
thank you
sorry about that I was on hit the wrong
button twice
um yeah I was in a long queue earlier so
for those folks saying like streamers
have a better whatever queue or server
it's not true at least not for me
everyone that was here earlier saw me in
a 40-minute queue
foreign
and leave my mother and Lilith care for
as long as that will take no
I'm going on
all right
shaking like leaves
foreign
[Applause]
what's special about this place anyway
what would draw a Lilith here
hell if I know prava doesn't tell us
anything no one goes in nothing comes
out that's all
no lift the jam must be deeper down
locked over here
um
there might be I didn't look at the um
settings at all there she goes
an enemies approaching nowhere to go
fights coming to us this time
wow that was
quick thinking
sure
Oliver hard to say there's been a lot of
people stuck in cues so probably more
people are saying L than W but I'm
having fun now that I'm back in fingers
crossed we can stay in for a bit
[Music]
right now I only have 12 this could have
got a third or a fourth but it wouldn't
really they're not like things I could
just like cast like a firewall or
something so I'm trying to get to the
next tree to get
um another castable spell on top of a
frozen horn
this
is
[Applause]
foreign
yeah
dead end
I'm not dying here
over there an opening
go
uh I don't know Marcus I didn't see it
but I also haven't been checking all the
loot as like um fervously as I would
just because I'm scared to get kicked
and just want to play as much to show
you guys the game as much as possible
the tunnel's closed
we're trapped without the look there she
is
okay
that statue
it's her
the way I saw her
I don't think we do Peter
finds my mother maybe I just got lucky I
don't I honestly don't know
[Music]
over there the whole
at last I'll ride out
a slave what happened
we need reinforcements
gamma how you doing
[Music]
what was it came from Beyond the gates
the escort
They're All Dead
over there
a woman
oh Maddie all I have to say no honestly
Maddie like you can say that if you want
but for anyone that was here earlier
watching me we all sat together in a 44
minute queue was I early to that yeah
and I'm sorry for anyone that's not in a
shorter queue but to say that we haven't
been in the keywords at first so I have
to be real about that
where
is
life give up girl
this is lost
you must listen this
for
me he is dead
I'm done for she bribed you with it
didn't she but it's not too late she can
still be saved not by me
not anymore
brother will know what to do
even leaving us abandoning her there's
nothing left to abandon
she's good as dead
sorry kid
he really just left us
it's up to us now
let's can't be too far
I haven't come across a dungeon yet so I
haven't tried to do party finder again
trying to like keep the variables as low
as possible just so that we can stay in
I'm woefully afraid of like more
disconnects Etc
daughter of hatred
I have
what do you seek
you dragged your child all over
Siri and pursuit of it
no I I taught her how to survive
is that
is that everything I've read has warned
me against you you've read so much
yet no so little I I don't know
will you let me try
I want to try your mother is
alive
he came this way with Lilith
how can you be sure
sometimes I see visions of the past
how Lilith's petals
her blood was fed to me once
[Applause]
believe it's June 6th thanks for release
date
God
[Music]
foreign
yeah okay just some dude those are the
crafting materials for like elixirs and
things like that which we'll try to
check out later when we upgrade our uh
feeling vile
thank you
[Music]
my frozen orb is really satisfying when
we get Hydra that it's pretty good too
and you get Hydra Frozen or really early
like we're like less than level 10. I
think Hydra Maybe by 12.
I was really surprised we got like the
powerful spell so early but it does feel
really good to have it like just right
off the bat so I I really enjoy that
oh I lied yeah Hydra is like in the
teens we can get there
yeah there
I would say diablo difficulty is never
always that hard even when you ramp up
it gets harder later right when you
um get to higher tiers of difficulty
when you get farther into end game when
there's more Monster density when
there's more monsters with higher spells
when you're going through your first
normal playthrough it's never going to
be that that hard right and you know
they need to cater across the board
right for new players returning players
hardcore Etc so you know right now we
can only turn it up to veteran I'm sure
you know as maybe there's more options
when it comes out but that'll that'll
change your experience right
[Music]
why you were spared
do you have faith in me
I
I want to
do good
for now
all you need now
we are going to meet
my son
rathma the first necromancer
here's the key to my plans
it sounds like they're searching for
Lilith's son rathma
together
are you thinking
good
[Applause]
yeah yeah
see how Frost Nova looks
that's pretty
I don't know that looks pretty good for
just a normal cross Nova no enhancements
or anything
[Applause]
thank you
I like the music
huh blocked again does Lilith know we're
coming
you've mastered your fear
I can't get rid of the companion Jacob
she's part of the story
you miss your daughter
my Magpie can't play with the controller
yes she's scared
with keyboard I'm not sure Jose Maybe
I
I trained her well you've chosen
we will need to cross a lake as you wish
mother good
you're ready for lesson one
here's the key
what did you see this time
I don't need sparing tell me
Lilith plans to teach your mother a
ritual one that needs blood
your mother seemed
receptive we have to reach them
oh I can't wait for ruined words lay the
sky like oh man throwbacks
[Applause]
I lack the needed
foreign
come on
explosion on Frozen is like so
satisfying
thank you
I was just about to say like in terms of
the the pacing of the combat like this
is pretty par for the course to D3 like
I think if anything D3 might be slower
because I feel like I don't know if it's
a visual thing but you know having
Frozen orb this early is a lot better
than what we had in D3 like honestly
like it was the same early level yeah I
mean if you're comparing it to like when
you're geared up and stuff like that not
even close right it's pretty far for the
course at least for my my opinion
all right
oh sorry unfortunately don't have meteor
yet but I will try to get to it if I can
assuming we can stay on I think the next
big skill will probably be a Hydra
this barrier it looks like the same kind
of magic as before
I think I can dispel it
I'm low
thank you
that is what I'm talking about right
there it's a monster density some some
high octane action
foreign
it takes it's gonna take me three more
just to get the Hydra so four it's like
12 levels away
um how long to get to 20 probably
two to three hours maybe three plus I
don't know hard to say we're leveling
decent right now we're like nine
[Music]
not enough blood Never Enough blood
I will follow you to the ends of
sanctuary mother
there she is
first like kind of mini boss fight here
I think
mother
You're Just in Time Beyond this lake
lies the necropolis of the first born
a trove of magic and knowledge
I opened the way for this
but
it could not pass through with her I
lack the vine element you see stop but I
can find it I'm so close
simply me mother stop look at what
Lilith has done to you
you're writing in your own blood my
little magpie
she awakened me
she showed me things
can't even put into words
once I finished you will understand I
don't care what she shows you please
let's just get out of here
oh I see yes clever Magpie
trying to Lead Me Away so you can take
all this for yourself
this is my discovery not yours
I will finish these rooms
oh God
oh
you must this
look at the gifts she's given me
yeah
mother no
won't take what's mine
foreign
I'm sorry I keep that fingering tab
instead of Q
yeah yeah
thank you
[Music]
you were protecting me
I don't want to hate you
I'm trying
I really am
we're going to make Lilith pay for what
she's done
so we need blessed blood
go back to your brother get that
blessing beg if you need to whatever it
takes
my mother started this damn ritual
I'm going to finish it
meets me in the Mistral Woods
why there
The Horizon hit a vault there
finding it with her life's work
Ed for that
maybe it will help with the ritual
if not
at least I can vary out where she'd want
I need time
I'm sorry just leave me
yes people can play this on PS5 Xbox PC
oh man town is rough right now
you're seeing the rubber banding is
happening to me in game
see that the kitchen is ready for the
model service
Angels Above you've returned
Reverend mother we want to hear of this
but she's away at corvallar seek your
blessing there
everything is unfolding as inarious
foretold
soon he will be free to escape sanctuary
and return to the heavens where he
belongs
[Music]
Anthony I could have more spells but I'm
trying to synergize my spell so that
we're just not all over the place I
could have spread my points differently
but again you can synergize your points
into like frozen orb greater Frozen orb
I could have just spammed having
multiple spells if we wanted but I don't
know that's just how I like to play
[Music]
you can redo your um skills at any point
um It's relatively
uh it's really I think in the beginning
it's like almost it's free for a bit and
then I think as you level up higher
it'll cost more but I think during like
the first 25 levels it's just gold so
it's pretty easy to respect if you
wanted to and then eventually we'll have
Paragon but not there yet obviously
oh did not know we had that
um
let me see if we can do any potions or
like elixirs
okay we can let we can I think oh I have
to be level 10 okay before I can upgrade
[Music]
uh I don't know if I can scroll out
anymore in terms of the camera this is
this is even this is zoomed in that's
zoomed out for now like just at normal
spec obviously
uh sorry you have 102 Minute Timer
Requiem greetings
I've seen other players you just saw one
that was like a had a green bar name on
it
um
so they're definitely in the world okay
let me out please
okay see here's a bunch of players right
here all the green names
what is this
[Music]
I want me to hop in this dungeon I think
there's one right here
then these aspects
um later on you can use them to like
craft certain things with them
um this one's a necromancer one so it
doesn't really help me but
happen if you want me to go into this
dungeon instead of story I'm happy to do
that
[Music]
all right people saying dungeon
there is couch co-op on Console gen I
think for PC you you have to have
multiple codes though
but um on consoles apparently as long as
you have one key and you sync your
Battlenet accounts you're supposed to be
able to do couch Co-op I haven't tried
it but that's what the uh the blog said
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
yeah yeah
[Applause]
right
here
yes
I say that shrine
come on veteran so the harder of the two
options
yes I'm pretty sure I am yeah
so what it'll look like when I logged
back in earlier
I got another skill because people want
to see more skills
[Applause]
wow it's weird it can't cross right here
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
okay
yeah yeah
let's go
thank you
about unless I gotta do something real
quick I'm sorry
oh you can take a look at these
legendaries that someone found
foreign
yeah yeah
oh I guess I'm making a rogue next
because I got that bow
[Applause]
foreign
yeah yeah
[Applause]
check out the new conduit shrine
[Music]
oh it turned into a lightning ball I
guess
not ready yet
[Applause]
thank you
guys I want another one of those where I
can't cross in between
[Music]
foreign
need blink
[Music]
yes
I do think the boss is behind that one
door though
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
I need time to prepare
[Applause]
my bags are full
so here's an aspect we won't be really
able to use it though because it's uh
for necro but it could be good for next
week
foreign
[Music]
trying to answer something
um that I got via message
has anyone tried cross platform play at
all listen carefully
you're also not going to get true
graphic Fidelity watching a stream
ery but
he arose
searching for blood
only I escaped
but you must see him
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I should probably head back to town to
get rid of all this junk plus also um
level my potion but
you know
we press on I think until we get another
Waypoint
[Applause]
it's locked
[Music]
all right
yes
thank you
all right so like a little mini event
there
clear out a bunch of waves
I was gonna get disconnected there
this is the blast we're trying
[Music]
[Applause]
how many necro asked oops even though so
many necro aspects from dungeons
would be nice to find one for uh
sorcerer sorcerers
it's locked
State your business
Reverend mother pravar expects me
open the gates
you are good soldiers
worked hard fought hard
drink hard too
Brothers
sisters
I hope you find peace in these flames
they go
what are you doing here
so you lived
I came clean to prava
about taking that woman's bribe
it's looking bad
my ass is on the line might not have a
job when she's done with me
hey
you're here for her right let's go
together
maybe she'll go easy on me if you're
there
not many could bear your sins
Brave of you to come back
hold
she's expecting us ah weird
I thought there'd be a waypoint in here
somewhere here you go
have the new Watch Commander replace the
forces we lost at the mine
so
you've returned
Vigo here tells me you were braver than
he
first you will be made worthy of a
blessing
a holy war cannot be won with faithless
troops
make no mistake this war is Holy
Lilith has brought the Eternal conflict
to sanctuary
and Denarius will deliver us as writ in
Prophecy
until then we have our parts to play
make a pilgrimage to the alabaster
Monastery cleanse your spirit
then we may discuss a blessing
always will make myself useful
come by the ruins south of here
kind of shocking there isn't a waypoint
here maybe I'm just not looking the
right spot
I want to say that thing might be a
stronghold
and I don't know if I'm strong enough to
do it I might be able to we can try
no I it didn't take me three hours it
took me about two hours
um Arceus sis because I got booted for
about 40 45 minutes
there's a shrine west of here there's a
relic
I'm told it takes on your sin weighs you
down Body and Soul Beats the hell out of
you
it'll cleanse you prepare you to stand
before the father
I hope you don't have many regrets
friend
this kind of thing is a lot deadlier for
some than others
watch out all right
I'll find you at the end
all right let's see what this is I don't
know if it's it's
it might not be a stronghold it might
just be a um event type thing we'll
check it out I think this is a waypoint
though
which is good
nope just kidding just looked like it
might be a waypoint
um we'll try whatever this is real quick
oh there's definitely a boss we'll see
if we can beat it or not
come on
foreign
wow
okay I guess that wasn't that hard
do I not get anything special for that
oh okay
foreign
beyond the reach of the light lift your
sins breathe deep the cold air the path
to Redemption lies before if you have
the faith
to walk it
all right
I need time
thank you
to feel the sting of your wounds let the
ice into your bones
welcome your pain for the agony of the
flesh is the first cleansing of the Soul
make your faith stronger
sorry for that lag it's in the game I
always thought I got kicked again though
feel how small you are
Embrace humility
your place in worship to the father
for he has shown us the way
I haven't killed that
[Applause]
pilgrim look into yourself
find your faith
feel how it fills the void within you
remember
you are nothing without faith
hold fast to the light
and remember
[Music]
so I like playing cards
doesn't make me a sinner
with that bribe could soldiers died on
the count of what I did
is that the kind of man I am
a kind I'll always be
I just damn it I'm praying why isn't
this working
you made it
that makes one of us at least you heard
from Brava I will soon but enough about
that
you're about to meet father in narius
himself
not everyone comes back you know
you better I I owe you a stiff drink
kneel before him and remember you are
small wonderfully small
this is how you choose to approach me
forgive this intrusion but tell me what
you need I must Traverse the Black Lake
and that cannot be done without your
blessing
if I've learned anything turn my time
here
is that what we're looking for
a rarely the same thing
but I once thought I could find an end
to this war but there has been no
resolution
cave
everything I've done has pulled me
further from home from the place I need
to be
this world we may be made was born
and yet like its creators
it rots from the inside
I
I don't
Lilith has entered the ancient city with
the old blessing I can pursue her
your kind of weak and this world has
been wasted on the Crusades of the
Unworthy I can stop her
this audience has concluded
Marius has no faith in us
foreign
that looks like it should be a waypoint
right
thank you
why would you say it's the worst
I don't tell me how I can enhance your
experience action
not necessarily but hey you know I'm
here to I'm here to ask the questions if
that's how they really feel
an outsider I could use your help a
dying night mistook me for his Confessor
he spoke of
sacrilegious things
he said his party of knights found a
secret to life
eternal a red chalice said the bishop
leading them ordered them to drink of it
deep
he confessed a shelter now in a place he
called the sanguine Chapel The Chalice
must be retrieved and I must leave find
me at the bear tribe Camp when you have
it
blessed are those who bask in the light
let our faith be our armor against the
encroaching Darkness
ah you've returned come I'm impressed
yet you stand before me unscathed
I know his ways
that is approval enough for me in the
name of the light I bless you
May the light flow through you and keep
you from corruption and sin
and you'll know not to that extent he's
prophesied
foreign
[Music]
fun so far it's been stable after that
first boot it seems like
Well you certainly have to look at
someone who spends a lot of time in the
Wilds
I expect you'll also want some of my
elixirs but let's focus on your healing
potion for now
some extra materials we can use this
time if you want to improve your healing
potion further or craft any elixirs
you'll need to Source your own
ingredients
I will not leave these walls never again
light keep you
thank you
[Music]
apologies was uh checking in on
something
[Music]
um
let's have a look at you
hmm
buckets nutrient forcing
this leather is correct
what have you been getting yourself into
huh
look you live or die by the quality of
your equipment
if you have the coin and materials I can
improve it for you I don't know what's
going on with that
you can take what's left
foreign
check to see if that is a stronghold
maybe
um we'll take a we'll take a look
huh
my husband Theodore left our home in the
middle of the night I heard him talking
to someone another woman
I went to confront them but they fled
towards a strange Light in the Forest
it gone all night
I think it's time I went after him but
the forest is dangerous would you
accompany me
sorry lady I shouldn't have picked up
your side quests we're going somewhere
else
More Strangers in the camp
oh wait a second was that that was the
quest that we did earlier huh
that's probably nothing then
[Music]
yeah okay that's not gonna work all
right
we'll go do this lady side quest
assuming she's even still with me
and then we'll see what I what we have
time for after that
[Music]
I'll do this side quests and then that
um dungeon and then if I call it a
stream
pissed
oh we can get it Hydra
yeah I want yeah probably Hydra
and there's a finally a sorcerer aspect
that you can put on a weapon
yeah we're running good so far Ramon
since uh or Roman since we uh got kicked
earlier but it's been good since then
I find this person's like husband though
my sweet fear dog
may you know uh what happened to this
man he has no skin
oh heavens no no
such sights I have witnessed
such pleasure
such pain
I must have
more
what
Theodore how is it that you
more
please go after that woman who did this
to him
more more more more more
peace
well that was awkward huh
it's no surprise Fedor was drawn to me
but I have given only what was desired
his Petty Soul has been torn asunder by
Agony and the Ecstasy but his flesh is
unyielding
you will not interfere
foreign
if it's a reward you won't take the
dagger from his chest
and leave me be you
thank you
all right
um gonna do this dungeon
going to try to see if we can do the
aspect thing and if we can I'll show
that to you and that'll probably be the
wrap of the stream but let's get through
this dungeon uh Hydra is pretty strong
um glad we picked it
[Music]
it was fun while last to chat
we made it a whole hour and a half I
think before we got kicked
foreign
see how bad this is
but I probably probably gonna call it
though I don't want to make it all sit
through another cue and
um but I had fun I'm glad we got to
um you know get Hydra there and show
Hydra off for like even the briefest of
minutes
um Necromancer is not till next week
but we'll check that out we're gonna
stream next week too hopefully not too
much queue time during during that uh
but we'll definitely check out either
Necromancer or Druid maybe we'll put up
a poll to see what people want to see
the day before or something like that
um
let me see I'm gonna give it a go and
try to get back in but I highly doubt
I'm gonna be I doubt I'm gonna be able
to get back in the game this is what
happened last time and then I had to
leave and then come back and then it
cued me basically
I'm pretty sure we're stuck though
oh you two will
man like it's like it's almost like will
you get like a certain amount of time
and they're like they're like okay we're
gonna kick these people to let the next
few people come in
I wouldn't even be shocked if maybe they
were doing that but
um
alrighty I think
um I'm not gonna put us back in Q hell
so I really appreciate everyone coming
by stopping by hanging out hope you all
were able to either get in and play or
get in later to play and
um yeah come back next week we'll we'll
be checking out the open Beta checking
out some of the new characters uh the
the Druid and the necro new in the sense
that you know we haven't played them yet
so
um thanks so much again y'all have a
good one
um you know really appreciate it again
and see y'all next time bye Voyage have
a great Friday have a great weekend you
know
bye